[Music]
on today's show we talked to a woman who
is dealing with arrogance and
self-loathing we talked to a woman whose
husband is a counselor and she doesn't
like him talking to other women about
sex
we talked to an awesome young mom who's
about to adopt a foster child and maybe
more stay tuned
[Music]
[Applause]
hey what's up everybody this is john
with the dr john deloney show
man i'm glad you're here
the show we talk about everything if you
want to be on this show i'm talking
about everything we're going to talk
about swimming i get we could i guess if
you want to call about swimming but um i
don't know a lot about swimming i'm
terrible at it
but we talk about mental health
relationships parenting holiday season
stuff
politics i don't care whatever you want
to talk about give us a call or go to
online go online to johndaloni.com
ask ask fill out the form
you can call us at 1-844-693-3291
leave a message and kelly will call you
back
speaking of
ben is on the mic
yes sir that sounds good hey what was
your uh childhood nickname we were
talking about this before well i was a
drummer so i always tried to get people
to call me ben jammin because that was
cool oh no
dude you kelly's like no
you can't nickname yourself
i i found that out oh oh no so what do
they morph it to because middle school
and high school kids are evil
i don't i think i just blocked it all
out after that and it didn't work
it's just been a steady
descent into madness which is how you
ended up on this show so we're glad
you're here kelly
well when i was little because kids are
mean it was kelly with a belly full of
jelly
so what people don't know was deloney
sent an email this week and supposedly a
typo
was to jelly and it brought up a lot of
[ __ ] did i write that i thought james
wrote that back no that was you
oh i called you jelly first i started
called me jelly yeah oh i did not intend
yeah i have i've probably slept four
hours in the last three weeks combined
so i didn't mean to call you jelly i'm
sorry for bringing all that up it's okay
hey well my last name rhymes with like a
processed lunch meat it was a rough
childhood too my nickname after that was
always because my maiden name is
fletcher so i've been and that's i was
in middle school when fletch came out so
i have been fletch forever even now half
my friends still call me fletch the most
common uh nickname i have besides
bologna which
way to go
i can't even repeat in public
yeah it's not great but there i've got
buddies whose parents are
70s and when i see them still to this
day that's what they call me and it's so
great i can't bring my kids around but
it's phenomenal it's just my name
and it is what it is and i realize to
everybody listening to this
hey you either don't care or b it's it's
like middle school and i just came up to
you and i'm like i know somebody who
likes you and i'm not gonna tell and i
ran off it's so lame but i just did that
i realized that it's kind of lame but
all right shake it off all right let's
go to shelly
oh my gosh
shelly rhymes with jelly but we won't
even go there shelly in atlanta what's
up shelley
yeah right with jelly that's awesome
we're not even going there we're not but
shelley does run with kelly but you
already sound kinder than kelly so
what's up
all right so last summer i was told that
i am arrogant
and
that was kind of a shock to me because i
think you may be more like kelly than we
thought so go ahead
i tend to have problems with
self-loathing and perfectionism i hope
kelly does not have that problem
no she doesn't have a problem with it
she just knows that she is perfect so
that's good
so
my negative automatic conclusion was oh
no i'm not hating myself enough or i
wouldn't look arrogant
exact way to go way to go
and i know that's not a healthy way to
think about it but
it's kind of been eating me alive ever
since then um
because i don't want to be arrogant and
that's the last thing i ever thought i
was i tend to really not think i'm
better than other people wow so who told
who told you this so
it was a work supervisor i
recently
came out of an abusive marriage and went
to
interview for a new job in a new place
and
um
i understood that you know when you do a
job interview you're supposed to sell
yourself and
um
you know sort of exaggerate how good you
are and i would say exaggerated but you
just tell them you those are one of the
few moments in our culture that we're
allowed to talk about ourselves
positively which is lame but that's
where we got so did you did you oversell
yourself or did you think you did a
great job
i felt like i did a good job i thought i
played the interview game well and i got
the job
but um
the supervisor later was like you know
you're kind of arrogant
based on that interview are based on how
you come into work every day and how
they experience you and here's what i'm
getting at two important things when
somebody says something like that to you
one is do they have credibility to speak
into your life
and if they don't then
just like jay-z you gotta brush your
shoulders off you gotta move on from
that i mean people are gonna there's
gonna be critics everywhere that's
that's life
if it's somebody that either a you need
them to
experience you in the right way someone
you love your spouse your parents
whatever
or your supervisor who
that your livelihood depends on them
being in relationship with you
um then that's a little bit more
important and so there has to have been
a series of behaviors of actions that
they experienced what were they
well so it was literally just based on
the interview
um
because i am
a sign language interpreter so i often
work by myself or
only
with people sometimes it's not like i
see this person every day or anything
like that
so it was
really just based on
the interview
okay
i thought i was a better interpreter
than everybody else
are you
no and i know that and i don't think
that
so
can you
i'm gonna i am going to
just shine my ignorance
brightly okay okay sure can you be
arrogant in sign language
obviously your words are but can you
come across that way
yes although the interview was in
english
okay so
how something else is going on here
because that one comment has caused you
to spiral out for a year
is that the first time somebody's told
you that
or are you really thin skinned like what
is it about that comment
i think that
i
it really took me by surprise and
um
you know it was it also came on
the heels of
my husband leaving me because i'm a
christian and he became an atheist okay
um so and there was abuse going on um so
did your husband did this have
does this have
ghosts of your relationship with your
husband telling you things about you
that you need to change you need to fix
that he doesn't like about you that
reasons that you're broken
um
criticism i mean i'm just trying i'm
fishing here yeah i mean he would tell
me things like you're just good at
making people feel sorry for you i don't
think
he thought i was arrogant he saw me go
into self-loathing a lot but i think it
just hit on
like that i'm a recovering perfectionist
and
that
anytime
someone says something about me i tend
to think it must be right and
and i have grown up as kind of the
the good child of the family and there
were
others of my generation that thought i
was stuck up or arrogant because i was
obedient okay so this is a lifelong
thing somebody wrote one of your bells
so here's something that happened to me
several years ago um a few universities
back where i worked
um
i applied for a job that i thought i was
a shoe-in
at least for a finalist position
and i didn't get an interview
which in that in my situation was a move
it was a statement
like i
like we're not even going to talk to you
about this
and so i i asked like man so i'm missing
something
and i thought i did good work i thought
i was a good guy
and
um
so a buddy of mine said man i'll ask
around and then he called and said hey
you wanna go to lunch it's my buddy mark
he called and said hey you wanna go to
lunch i said yeah
and um he said i'm gonna be honest with
you here's what i heard and
what came back
was devastating to me
and here's why i'm uncomfortable in
certain academic settings i've always
struggled with whether you're smart
enough that's why i keep going to grad
school to to prove myself to myself it's
ridiculous but that's me
and
i feel uncomfortable around really smart
people because i'm i'm intimidated by i
like being around them so much and i
love good engagement but
um i don't always fit at those in those
tables and i don't like
i'm uncomfortable in banquet-y kind of
situations
i love them when i'm there but just i
this takes a season to get it i got to
gear up for it
and so what i often do is i spend a lot
of time in the back of those rooms
meeting with the sitting with the
students or sitting with
um the police officers the security
officers or sitting with the custodial
staff
that's where a guy grew up my dad was a
police officer my dad would work
custodial stuff on the weekends like
it's just who i grew up
and
the feedback came back was you're a
slick politician
that you walk around the room and you
glad hand everybody and you always spend
your time trying to look like you're
with these people
and it was the exact opposite of what i
was
trying to do because i wasn't trying to
do anything other than be comfortable
and but the feedback was good and so i
had to make a decision number one am i
going to stop being comfortable in my
professional life the answer is no
no number two
is there some things that i took from
that feedback like hey here's how you
come across absolutely and he was right
he was absolutely right when i when he
explained how i walk into a room i was
like oh my gosh that guy looks like an
idiot and he's like well that guy's you
and so i took some wisdom from that
here's what i think about self-loathing
i think self-loathing
can be hitting the pendulum so far the
other way that you end up in the exact
same places on the other side of the
spectrum
you know what i mean like i
i want to follow the rules i want to be
a perfectionist hey you missed a rule
here
well
i must be the worst person ever which is
the same thing as i must be the best
person ever just on the other side of it
it's just living in these dramatic
swings
and you labeled yourself a bunch in this
call
and you live by these labels
and i want to see you live a life free
of labels
like shelly what do you want what do you
want in your world
what do i want yeah what do you want you
get one how old are you
30. 30. so you're 33 done
33
you're 33 done
and
in some statistical models you're about
halfway you're almost halfway done
depending so i like to just go on the
long end of that tail
you only get one of these
one
and it's tiny and it's quick and it's
precious
what do you want to do with it
i mean i would like to make a difference
in people's lives
that's external that's you fishing what
do you what do you want
to be happy and accepted i guess
to be loved who told you you couldn't be
loved
besides your ex-husband
probably myself
yes like
that i can't be loved if people think
i'm arrogant or
um if people think
something about me that's not true it
automatically is true because i thought
it so here's what
i want you to do when somebody drops
that brick in your backpack someone
tells you something about you
you're not pretty enough you're too big
you're too skinny you're too this you're
too jesusy you're not jesus enough
you're you swear too much you're such a
goody goody with your language whatever
it is
you're arrogant because of an interview
where you told everybody you flexed a
little bit good for you you told
everybody i'm
i'm a incredible um
sign language
i can rock it onto the break of dawn
when it comes to sign language everybody
better recognize and get in line behind
shelly
shelley jelly and
they said hey you came across as
arrogant
i want here's what i want you to do
keep a small journal go to walmart or
target or if you're an overbuyer over
buy it
and have a small journal and it's just
your story journal and carry it with you
everywhere i have a small one in my bag
right now
and
when somebody says dude you're arrogant
or you're a jerk or you are filling the
blank
or when those thoughts pop in your head
about you
i want you just to write it down
and
extend it out arm's length physically
and ask yourself is this true
and if it's not
you have to then decide i'm gonna stop
dwelling on it
you don't make that decision you let
your mind
control you
and i want you to take back control of
your thoughts
so how do i know if i'm arrogant
are you
i mean
i
i
value myself and i don't know i'm
valuing myself as arrogant
do you have somebody that you trust
do you have a friend a community
some yeah
ask them
so i did ask my sister what she said and
she
she said
um she said i know that you
have some insecurities and so i know
where that comes from it can look
arrogant but i know
like in your heart it's not so when she
says look arrogant what are the things
that look arrogant
like
um
are you mean to people do you talk do
you cut in line do you say oh my gosh
i'm so much better than that than you
look at my body compared to yours my bag
is nicer than your i mean
here's here's what here's the here's the
challenge these thoughts swirl around
and they're hard to grab onto and they
spin faster and faster and then
you start looking for confirmation of
them everywhere and you'll find it
and somebody will look at you a little
bit weird and you'll go oh it's cause
i'm arrogant or somebody will say oh
excuse me ma'am and you'll go oh they
think american you'll see it everywhere
and that's why i want you to write it
down and get some distance from it and
then begin to pull it apart what are the
things is it how i stand
is it how i am rude do i talk sharp with
people does my voice get loud what are
the details of this thing that we can
work on
mine was i walked in and shook hands in
a particular order throughout a room i
looked exactly like a slick politician
and it grossed me out
so one of the things i stopped doing was
shaking hands i don't like
i just stopped shaking hands and i
walked by and i look people in the eye
and say dude what is up and i stopped
trying to like be a professional engager
and i just started being a human engager
and it literally went away and so there
was some behavior things that i could
fix i didn't change who i hung out with
in a room i didn't change how i honored
the president of that was in that room
and the custodial staff in that room all
that stayed the same but i did stop
going from person to person and shaking
hands and nodding my head like a tv
politician and so there was some actual
things i could do that were different
that's what i'm asking you what are the
things people point to
i don't think they've really pointed to
anything just maybe the way
i talk that's a thing that's a thing
that's an action yes okay so the way you
talk
so like in the interview you know i
would say things like um
i think they talked about how they're so
so busy and don't have enough people to
handle it and i was like so you all need
me
or um
you know they were like
you know i told them some of the
experience that i had that was not
expected
that like they wouldn't have thought i
had that experience
as a young interpreter and they took
that to mean that i was arrogant
gotcha well so here's the deal you can't
control what they think you control how
you live
and so from this point forward when you
hang up the phone here
if you're not an arrogant person we're
done with the conversation
and
begin being conscious about
kindness and leaning into people now
that you've got this job
love people and by the way
if they need you say that
you see what i'm saying like i don't
hear anything arrogant here i hear
somebody who is so
so incredibly tied to what the words
that come out other people's mouths for
her own security
that you will just spin and flip and
flop and do whatever it takes
for the per the next person in front of
you to value you
and what i want you to do is to get past
all of that and you begin to value you
and then you speak your truth out loud
and there will be certain people that
don't want to be around that truth and
that's okay they get to choose that
and there will be certain people that
gravitate towards that truth and it will
be incredible
but until you decide
i'm shelley and i
i am i'm worthy of my space
i am worthy of my jokes
i think these things are funny and i
think these are not funny and i'm okay
with that and i've got these opinions
and i'm willing to be wrong until you
can start to root yourself in the ground
there
you're just gonna have what you're
experiencing now one person's gonna say
one thing and it will spin you up for a
year it'll take up a year's worth of
thought real estate in your mind
and
it will mess with your biochemistry it
will make you live less long
because it will poison you every time
you talk to this person your heart's
going to start beating a little faster
and you can dump a little bit more
cortisol and adrenaline in in your
bloodstream it's going to slowly eat
your insides
but yeah i mean it's become kind of a
lens of like oh man i want to draw a
boundary here but i can't because
they'll interpret it as me being
arrogant and you can't control other
people
all you can control is your thoughts and
your actions
and
you can draw really firm boundaries with
kindness
and you can draw really firm boundaries
with joy people who
don't have strong internal sense of who
they are
they have to they often overcompensate
their boundaries they wait till it
builds and builds and builds and they
kind of explode on people
and then people go whoa
instead of the slow
regular
gentle making a boundary
hey can you do this yeah i can do that
can you do this yeah i can do that can
you do this no i need a weekend whoa
chill out
versus hey can you do this i'm out this
weekend but i would love to get to it
next monday i'd love to
that's a that's a boundary making
one small boundary at a time
and all of that comes back to do you
think you're even worth your own
boundaries
do you think you're worth saying no
do you think you're worth saying yes
do you think you're a person of kindness
sit down with somebody that you trust
and say let's look at these behaviors
how do i interact i want people when
they
interact with me i want them to come
away feeling
joyful i want them to come away feeling
like i'm a little bit happy after
talking to that person
that's what i want so let's work on
those actions and your heart may never
change here because your heart's
probably good
but your heart has to be plugged into
you
you got to be okay with you and you're
not
and that's where i want you to start
writing down a piece of paper
what do i want
let's backfill it how do we get there
thank you so much for the call shell
we'll be right back on the dr john
delaney show
[Music]
hey what's up this delony let's talk
about getting a good night's sleep it's
important for your physical health your
mental health your relation health for
your sanity you name it sleep is
important if you're not sleeping good
one of the first questions i want you to
ask is do i need a new mattress
here's how you tell are you tossing and
turning all night because you can't get
comfortable are you waking up in the
middle of the night burning hot or in
the morning does your back hurt if you
have any of these issues you may need a
new mattress
check out dream cloud it's a mattress i
have in my own house you will love it
and they're currently running their
biggest offer of all time
400 bucks in accessories plus an
additional 250 discount only for delony
listeners that's a total of 650 bucks in
accessories and savings visit
dreamcloudsleep.com deloney or
dreamcloudsleep.com and enter promo code
deloney to get a new mattress shipped to
your house today and you can enjoy 650
bucks in savings
that's
dreamcloudsleep.com promo code
d-e-l-o-n-y
all right we are back let's go to
samantha in chicago what's up samantha
hey how are you just rocking onto the
brick of dawn how about you
awesome doing great excellent so what's
up
all right so my husband's currently in a
graduate program to become a christ a
christian licensed professional
counselor so i wanted to call in and get
your perspective um more specifically i
haven't heard of specializing
i haven't heard of so is he getting his
lpc
yeah he's getting his lpcc at a
christian university with the plan to
specialize in drug and alcohol recovery
at a christian facility wherever that's
going to be so he he
he's getting he's going to become a
licensed counselor and he happens to be
a person of faith
yeah and actually through as he's going
through the program he's realizing
more and more
while
the whole world needs help it will be
difficult for him to
kind of
intertwine jesus and in that part to the
spiritual healing of people in kind of
secular institutions so he's kind of
targeting specifically drug and alcohol
recovery because um that's part of his
testimony how he came to christ as well
as
christian organizations so that's kind
of
what he's working towards and i'm
totally supportive of that and when we
met you know he was he was uh in his
undergrad for
psychology and counseling and um he was
kind of focusing more towards uh
counseling men so he went through a
christian christian recovery program
that was men only and he's planning to
intern at that
place as well okay but
as we're we got married a year ago and
and this is kind of um
i've been christian three years he's
been christian six years where our first
relationship since being christian so
trying to apply things from the bible
and marriage and and boundaries with
opposite sex has been uh just a
challenge in a lot of different areas so
when it comes to friendships and
even i work in finance so the nature of
my job is not spiritually or emotionally
intimate but in any case if i have
meetings or one-on-one um with men or
anything like that it's it's all
transparent you know that's the type of
stuff that we can talk about so some of
my struggles or concerns with if he does
decide to also counsel women
it's just i have a lack of comfort with
that because
generally counseling is private it's
it's one-to-one often behind closed
doors and definitely confidential you
know there's
there's a lot of intimate topics that
are discussed i myself am in counseling
and so is he so we we know what kind of
things are
talked about and while i do understand
it's one way it's client to counselor
honestly i just don't really like the
idea of a woman another woman sharing
their hearts and soul with my husband
and kind of believe that's reserved for
marriage
now i do trust him
but i do know that we're sinners at
heart and
for me it's just kind of it just doesn't
feel safe like we're putting in good
boundaries or safeguarding when there
are great options to just counsel men
and
hold on
let me break in here let me break in
here
um
so i'm going to say this as kindly as i
can but as directly as i can okay
your marriage is not safe right now
okay
um
you have some very
deep trust challenges with the person
either with yourself or the person
you're married to
and
whether you're
i don't care what your faith persuasion
is
i don't care
what
your
professions are
you all need to get together asap
and deal with the trust issues
whether you're bringing them to the
table and you've been hurt in the past
or you've made bad decisions in the past
or this guy has made bad decisions in
his past etcetera
right a counselor is
like a surgeon
like a doctor
like a plumber they are trained
professional and part of the training is
how to remain objective how to be honest
with yourself how to sit in consulting
how to fill in the blank is counseling
intimate you better believe it is
but is there a difference between that
relational intimacy that happens in a
professional setting
and sexual intimacy there better be or
that person shouldn't be a therapist
yeah yeah and so and i know just trust
issues i know i have that so i'm aware
and i'm an individual counseling
associate and we we are also in marriage
counseling so we're covering all the
bases and ultimately it's
going to be prayers with god so actually
what i'm doing and i've sought this out
with other um like a woman professional
counselor
and asked this question too because what
i want to do is to get other
perspectives that are different than my
own
more objective so the i think that
besides the trust issues which
for sure is is ongoing and for me it's
not just like um the counseling job we
just have
or myself uh personally just issues when
it comes to op this is sex but the the
one
aspect that
i really struggle with and
i i think it is outside of the trust
issue is understanding that it is a
profession and there's ethics and
standards and everything that counselors
abide by
to me it's different than being a
plumber or a surgeon that is doing
surgery because this is like emotional
and spiritual intimacy
that another woman is sharing but the
biggest part of that is
the confidential nature of counseling so
if i'm experiencing
you know
emotionally intimate conversations with
another man in whatever setting or i'm
going to a male doctor these are all
meetings and
meetings that i could share with my
husband it's not something that he can't
know about or he can't know about you
you're getting exactly you're you're
making my point for me this has nothing
to do with counseling
at all
this has to do with the fact that your
husband's going to have a part of his
life that you won't have access to and
something about that makes you crazy
yes exactly and so
that that is
your
challenge to work through
and this is
you've got to be okay with it
i know but when it comes to
you know being a christian and the
covenant and sacredness and transparency
of marriage to me it feels like okay
we're supposed to be one we're supposed
to just be in each other's lives and
total transparency between the two of us
and then then there's this major part of
his life that he'll be spending you know
more time in because
work is generally more time than with
family and it's something that
i can't have access to because of the
nature of the job and to me that it
feels like a violation to
marriage
and so what you're conflating in a
dangerous way is
open access
and trust
trust is faith is i'm leaning into you
and you're leaning into me
and about the things that you want to
share with me
i trust that you're honoring this
relationship
i trust that you're honoring me
so let's imagine you have some
rambunctious dream
about an ex-boyfriend
do you feel like that you're violating
your husband's trust if you don't wake
him up in the middle of the night and
tell him about what you just dreamt
or is there some stuff you go oh
i'ma hang on to that one
and if
i'm just
this you are using faith
you are using your christian beliefs
you are using this idea of intimacy in
marriage
and one with somebody else
as an excuse to read his diary
as an excuse to get into his client's
folders
and this is you're conflating two things
that have no business being together
it's dishonoring
it is unethical it's wrong
to get into somebody else's life if they
haven't invited you in
and in the profession that your husband
is choosing they have invited him into
that
and you mentioned the doctor but you
mentioned on the other side of it
meaning
you do if you go have a a doctor visit
um with a male doctor you can come go
around and tell everybody
he cannot
he can't go home to his family and say
well i saw so-and-so without her shirt
on today here's what it looked like
here's this here's it can't do that
that's your privacy
and so you want one side of the
teeter-totter but you expect the other
and it doesn't work like that
yeah and so what i'm telling you is a
there is some wisdom
you're new at this site your faith is
young your faith is new and you are
going all in on it and i honor that good
for you
and it sounds like you love this guy so
so much
that you want to share dna i mean you
want to line your souls up together
right
i almost said you want to share dna and
then i realized that's probably not the
right way to say that um well you know
if we have a kid i guess it's very
technically true but you want to
mirror at the at the genetic level and
you can't
and so the piece you have to make is
what does trust look like what does
faith in somebody else look like
when i can't know everything that my
friend is love
yeah and i wonder um from your
perspective with counseling probably
anyone regardless of gender just just
high level do you have some like
ideas of what are some good boundaries
like some some counselors have told me
like they don't share their personal
number you know they don't take calls
outside of work hours but
the thing i was thinking is like
something that could help me besides
obviously individual counseling and
continuing
prayer with god is
is healthy boundaries but it's hard to
know what's healthy right now because of
just all the other stuff that i'm
dealing with yeah and you are trying to
make his boundaries for him his
professional boundaries for him because
you're uncomfortable
yeah
and
again you are getting into somebody
else's
head and thinking their thoughts for
them and then you are trying to respond
to those thoughts that haven't even been
thought yet
and you're wearing yourself out
yeah you're exhausting yourself
and you're trying to duct tape this all
together through a young new faith
and it's becoming it's it's slowly
pulling you underwater
to the point that you are wondering if
he should even be doing what he wants to
be doing with his life
yeah yeah and you come at him with
verses
and chapters
and
when he's trying to do an assignment or
doing his practicum or doing whatever
and
what i'm telling you is your marriage
is on really shaky ground
yeah
and so the question is not are there
good boundaries and practices absolutely
that people have do different therapists
have different roles yes some are super
firm
some are more open access like i am your
therapist you can reach me at this time
i think that's dangerous but
not and not for sexuality stuff even
though that's an issue
let me be super clear with you
counselors sleep with their clients
it happens yeah and that is you will get
your license taken away and you will
never be able to
um be in somebody's intimate life again
and that should be that way
anyone who ever sleeps with a client
should immediately be stripped of their
license period
and who kisses a client hold hands with
i mean there is no romance in that
setting
right right
if you tell your husband i'm
uncomfortable these things you're
allowed to do that you're allowed to
feel those things
and then he's going to have a choice
so i don't want to dishonor your
feelings
but i want to tell you that the feelings
you have are deeper than just this
profession
because what's going to happen is he's
going to quit he's going to be a plumber
and then you're going to say
where are you going to so into his house
to fix the dishwasher he's like yeah i
just got some client her name is susan
and you're going to say was there going
to be any men there
and you'll say i don't know i'm just
going to fix the dishwasher at this
address so there's just going to be a
woman there and then that's going to
make it bananas yeah like they'll always
be something always be something
that's a good point and whether it's a
lawn business or a restaurant when you
took that woman's cash did you touch her
hand like it's always gonna be a thing
yeah and so at some point when you are
married when you love somebody
i have to trust that my wife had an
experience today and she chose not to
tell me for a reason
i have to trust that
it may be that whenever she tells me
about some guy that was rude to her i
bow up like well i'm gonna go fight him
or i'm gonna call him or i'll let him
know and she doesn't want to deal with
me maybe i've made her unsafe
or maybe she's a big
grown-up grown woman
and
she she's not big by the way i'd realize
i might get in trouble for that she is a
grown-up she's a grown woman
and she can decide whether you know i
mean that's her choice
and there's certain things i've said hey
if this happens please let me know and
she is then said i'm going to honor you
by doing that or that violates my
boundaries and i'm not comfortable with
that and then we negotiate those things
but somewhere in your core honey you
have a
major
major chasm with trust
and i don't know if it's from your
childhood i don't from your your
previous romantic relationships but it
is heavy and you're trying to solve it
by knowing every second of every
moment of every
interaction with your husband and you're
gonna make yourself nuts
and you're gonna burn the relationship
to the ground
and so as you move forward with trust as
you move forward yes he has to have
professional boundaries that's between
him and his counseling supervisor
yes there's going to be things of of
comfort if he's cheated on you if he
comes home and he's like man this woman
was talking about sex and it kind of
turned me on he probably shouldn't be a
therapist
but you are allowed to say hey these
things make me uncomfortable right now
i'm not comfortable with you
uh counseling x y z that's fair had
those conversations
but i want you to go deeper because you
got to deal with your trust issues this
is about your marriages isn't about his
job right now the job y'all could talk
about later
i want you all to deal with the trust
issues here because you're worth
being able to breathe and right now you
can't breathe
trust is so so hard especially when it's
been broken
but you can't heal it
it's got to be intentional about dealing
with that not the personal issues deal
with the trust we'll be right back on
the doctor john deluxe show
one of the most common questions folks
ask me is what they should do when
anxiety or panic strikes like a
lightning bolt i've been helping folks
101 for years but i wanted to create
something that everyone could use
anywhere at any time so i created a free
guided meditation it's not really a
meditation but really me just walking
with you through your anxiety alarms
from start to finish i'll guide you
through a breathing exercise and show
you how to lean in listen and head
towards healing it is free and it's for
everyone you can download this guided
meditation today for free at
johndaloni.com
all right let's take uno mas let's go to
dana in saint paul
st paul what's up
good morning doc thanks for taking my
call thanks for calling what are you
doing
um well you know
i got a little interesting interesting
thing for you so hey talk directly into
the phone i can barely barely hear you
and you're too smart
i'm sorry how's that can you know
a little bit more
uh how about
can you hear me does that live yeah now
we're talking or as they uh now we're
cooking with grease is that what they
say i don't know how they say it in
texas no no whatever i just made
everything weird all right so what's up
my husband and i we're in the process of
adopting my foster son
uh who's been with us since he was a
baby congratulations that's awesome
thank you thank you so much so our plan
uh was to be traditional foster parents
but he's wonderful we can't imagine our
life without them so you know we decided
to adopt them and the plan was to close
our foster care license after the
adoption
so we just found out that um bio mama is
pregnant again
and because of uh adopting our son the
county is going to call us for placement
of this new uh baby
so my husband's open to being the
traditional foster parent uh for this
baby until there's a permanent placement
available
but uh john he's a big softie so i feel
like no matter what he's going to fall
in love with his baby again like we did
with our son
and i'm really
not sure what to do knowing that i would
be so attached and our house is going to
be bothered again and i'm really not as
polite about the foster care adoption
system as i was when i started this
right because you know we were a little
more educated at this point
that system will abuse you yes
it will beat the crap out of your soul
and your marriage and everything yes
exactly exactly
so knowing how
isolated adoptees feel
um my motivations for adopting this baby
or bringing this new baby in
would be
so my son and this
baby their his brother or sister
would have a
person that they're more deeply
connected to that
i guess we would really never understand
because my husband and i are not adopted
sure biokidos are not adopted
so i got two part questions for you yeah
okay get together but
so just so i can repeat this so i can
make sure i haven't lost it
you're about to you've been fostering a
young child you're about to adopt him
and then
his mom
is pregnant
and the county's gonna call you which of
course they do once they got you and
they're like well how about 14 more so
they they're gonna call you and say hey
would you want to adopt
this
your um new adopted child's
sibling
and
you are thinking
i'm in and you know out the gate
husband's gonna be like
or it's just a mess
it's um
we keep flip-flopping back and forth
sure
absolutely we're oscillating between
excitement fear panic more fear
um so that's every parent ever always
it just used to happen real fast
yeah i mean when you it's a biological
kid you get nine months to flip out
about that
when it's when it's adopted kid you get
about 36 hours
yeah it's a ramen noodle of babies you
know they call you and hey come get them
yeah and you're like like you're in line
at sonic and they're like hey you want a
kid come get it right now cut right now
right now right now and you're like
uh-huh and yeah there's no way to win
that because then if you say no then you
torture yourself forever and if you say
yes you're like oh we have a human
yeah totally okay so what's your
question now
so what should we be asking ourselves to
examine our intentions
our bandwidth about possibly taking this
baby in
knowing that it is going to change the
factors of our lives either way whether
we say yes or no right and how do we
continue to communicate with each other
as we kind of cycle through all these
emotions without over analyzing or
spiraling into a deaf spiral of worry
because we're the type of people that
deal with things as they come we try not
to over analyze or worry but this is so
big
yeah do you have uh do you have
biological ki by the way great question
what a genius man you're awesome
um and what a good soul good for you
uh i wanna yeah never mind good for you
you're awesome um
do you have your own biological kids
yes how old are they
um i got a six and a four-year-old oh so
you're in it to win it
oh yeah yeah uh i mean you're you
already went from man-to-man to zone you
can add another 11 kids who cares
yeah that's kind of what i see
i'm totally kidding 11 is a lot um
so
here's here's the way i would frame it
in the way you you're starting to
articulate it in just the right way
which is such a gift and if i could get
everybody on planet earth including
myself to live as you just articulated
this the world will be a better place
there has to be pockets in our life
where we just talk crap
where we just go
and people don't try to race to solve
those
things we can just have our feelings
come out of our bodies and then we go on
about our day
moments we can say i don't like you
to your husband
because he left his muddy shoes on the
back porch again whatever
that doesn't mean you want to leave him
that doesn't mean you should be looking
for another husband that doesn't mean i
don't like you right now of course i
love you of course i'm not going right
we have to be able to do that and we're
so
pindle me in our culture these days
i'm totally in love i hate you i need
somebody else right back and forth so
you have to have that moment and you
have to have that moment of we get a
solve right right in front of us and
look 5 10 20 years down the road
yeah and so it's both and so here's what
i would challenge you with
number one
commit to you and your husband we are
going to live with no secrets
and
so okay start with no secrets
secrets are
you know brene brown says you know shane
meet secrets for breakfast shame i mean
secrets always end up in resentment
because it builds and builds like i
don't really when the more i think about
this the more i just
i i cannot have another kid in this
house
or
i cannot not adopt this baby
but we need to put a period within of a
sentence because this birth mom may go
on to have five other kids and we can't
do this every time so what is our cap
gonna be
and it makes it when you start talking
about cap what is our capacity how much
money do i mean when you start being
honest with yourself it's less about hey
we're holding this little baby and we're
able to look at our our capacity and our
boundaries at arm's length
and that starts with no secrets
where are you on this
and i would have the no secrets
conversation like maybe once a week
that's not an everyday thing because
your feelings vacillate
i can't do another baby just cause today
was hard i'm
tired yeah that was yesterday yes and
then you woke up today and you're like
today's great and your six-year-old came
and got in bed with you and your
four-year-old made their own their
cereal everywhere but they tried you
know i mean and suddenly you go
oh gosh they just wiped their own butt
it's gonna be okay you know what i mean
and
so you have it vacillates and so
it's being able to have a place where
you can say
like plan for it all right we're let's
do a heart check in
what secrets are building up and
everybody can have their secrets out and
then the other way to that i want as an
everyday thing
is
to preface a sentence with i'm being
vulnerable here
okay and the phrase i'm being vulnerable
here sets up a conversation that goes
very one i mean only one way
i'm being vulnerable here i don't know
that i could handle a fourth baby
and what that means is i'm just getting
that out into the ether and the other
person cannot respond all they can say
is thank you for sharing that period
that's it
and what they're going to do over the
course of a week is they're going to
listen and kind of absorb
not kind of i hate people say that
they're going to listen and absorb
the vulnerable statements and over the
course of one week two weeks four weeks
if there's been multiple i'm just being
vulnerable here
i cannot wait to have a fourth baby i
want that baby
or i'm being vulnerable here i don't
know if i can handle it i i i i feel
like i'm at the end of my capacity
then during the secrets conversation the
once a week and this is when y'all gonna
look at your budget this is gonna be
when you look at your calendar for the
week so it doesn't have to be a a big
kumbaya throwing confetti in the air
it's just a planned interaction
checking in where are you how are you we
doing okay
and
that's when somebody can say all right i
heard you say five or six times last
week this baby's the idea of another
baby is overwhelming where where walk me
through where you're at
and so i may in a week say i'm being
vulnerable here
i don't have any friends i'm super
lonely i'm exhausted and i don't my our
pet's heads are falling off i'm just
gonna go and go and go
and
then at the end of the week my wife's
gonna say all right you were in three
different states in three different time
zones
and four days
you seem like you're tired
you talk to me about being lonely let's
circle back to that and then by then i
might have slept and i'll go yeah dude
i'm fine i just miss my buddies i'm fine
or i can say no man the more i thought
about it the more i need to be more
attention about does that make you hear
here i'm going with this
yeah i love it i think it's such a great
uh it's such a tactic that we could we
could just immediately implement uh to
help yes and then the third one and this
is like an immediate thing
this is i recommend this when couples uh
are thinking about ivf
when you couple start thinking about um
ivf and they start thinking about
um
you know going down that road i want
them to have the end in mind how far
will you go how much money will you
spend
because that can become a bottomless
well
and you can look up four years later and
you can be 160 000 in the hole
have
15 fertilized embryos and zero kids
or you can get pregnant on the first
alright so i want people to what how far
are we willing to go on this deal i want
you and your husband to take a half day
go do an inventory of life
get somebody to come watch your kids um
you've got a six-year-old a
four-year-old a newborn and you might
get another another newborn
i want you all to just
take an inventory where are we
do we still like each other when's the
last time we had sex that we wasn't
someone wasn't wearing like a like a
there wasn't a diaper bag on the bed too
and when is the last time we went on a
date and how are we are we exercising
like i want you to do an inventory of
your life
and then say how many do we want any
more biological kids
how many humans can we have in our
little house how many humans can we
afford i want you all to just to map out
where things are
and then plan for the end and then if
you say we had the capacity for a kid
now we have to ask ourselves do we want
one
okay what would that look like for us
and then the no secrets be vulnerable
and
hey
you should be feeling
crazy
you should feel nuts
i have a six-year-old and a
four-year-old you should think twice
about getting a goldfish
that's just another being that might die
so yeah
everything should be chaos that
shouldn't be the litmus test the litmus
test should be much more practical
and much more spiritual and what i mean
by spiritual is uh hopefully you're
you've got a faith community that you'll
pray through with this and if you don't
there's the cosmos is bigger than this
for you this would be a big thing i'm
praying about every day that i'm
journaling about i'm making sure that i
am whole with the decisions i'm making
and that me and my wife are connected on
this stuff and that my kids are brought
into the conversation and all that all
that all that you know that goes
be vulnerable give yourself places every
day where you can go and just release
some of the steam and the feelings the
exhaustion i just need you to hear me
and then the here's where i really am
once a week or so and then man go get
them go get them
good for you fabulous advice i really
appreciate it doc all right let me know
how things go go on that half day
retreat and set the stage for what's to
come and by the way this will be great
for your marriage just in general and if
you're listening to this and you have
two kids do it this weekend just take a
half day and say whoa where are we if
you got two kids that are 19 and 20 you
got two kids that are six and four
and if you're thinking about adding a
couple of others oh god i might do that
too all right as we wrap up today's show
hey yesterday kelly what was that guy
who did his debt-free scream yesterday
in the lobby
the crisis responder
oh yeah earlier this week yes guy was
amazing
and he's a crisis responder so he works
for emergency response he's an
incredible guy and we came out and he
was just really complimentary he said
some kind things which
i don't get a lot from folks like y'all
here so i believe he also told you that
i was very nice and you told him that
that was not true i that may or may not
have happened i cannot confirm cannot
confirm but
i said you get to pick the song of the
day
and he said great so this is the song he
picked
off the everywhere we go album kenny
chesney
she thinks my tractor's sexy and it goes
like this
plowing these fields in the hot summer
sun
over by the gate lordy here she comes
with a basket full of chicken and a big
cold jug of tea sweet tea i make a
little room and she climbs up on
open up the throttle and stir a little
dust just look at her face she ain't
fooling me she thinks my tractor's sexy
it really turns her on great song dude
she always staring at me while i'm
chugging along she likes the way it's
pulling while we're tilling up the land
she's even kind of crazy about my
farmer's tan
she's the only one who really
understands what gets me she thinks my
tractor's sexy
i love america this is the dr john
delaney show
[Music]